at an emergency cabinet meeting called
to discuss the deepening rift with Japan
president moon jae-in of South Korea
laid the blame squarely with his
neighbor Yong Morioka wha-hoo Japan's
decision is a reckless decision that
rejects diplomatic efforts to solve the
problem and rather worsens the situation
I express my deep regret he was
responding to the latest escalation in
the trade dispute with Japan removing
South Korea from the so called white
list of countries allowed to receive
exports of sensitive strategic
components that it needs for its
high-tech manufacturing it comes on top
of restrictions last month on the export
of raw materials for the production of
semiconductors in South Korea with fears
of a knock-on effect to manufacturing in
neighboring countries Japan denies it's
linked to a decades-old dispute over its
wartime record a scandal this move was
approved to revise Japan's export
controls appropriately and was not
intended to hurt Japan South Korea
relations or to craft countermeasures
Japan has been angered by a Supreme
Court ruling in favor of victims of
forced labor during World War two with
several Japanese firms ordered to pay
compensation that's despite Japan's
insistence that an agreement in 1965 was
meant to have resolved the issue once
and for all
but those studying the history of the
turbulent relationship say it's clear
the two sides have always held opposing
views on the nature of that agreement
those are ye up until now they have
lived with their separate
interpretations but this state of
agreeing to disagree has been shaken and
can no longer stand after this court
decision and now we are at a most
critical juncture in korea-japan
relations South Korea has promised a
firm response without specifying exactly
what but it seems intent on retaliation
rather than reconciliation Roblin bride
al jazeera
south korea